[Music]
it's late summer in the highland forests
of mexico billions of fireflies are
hiding in the underbrush waiting for the
perfect night to find a mate but most
nights something is off and so they keep
waiting the fireflies before a moonless
night so only their language of light
will shine in the dark and the females
prefer to lay their eggs on a rainy day
when the airs still for the fireflies of
Mexico conditions are perfect for just a
few hours each year to see their
marvelous display you must walk miles
into the woods carrying only a dim
natural flame for light and if you've
chosen the right place on just the right
day
when night falls the fireflies go into a
frenzy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and in one magical hour the fireflies of
Mexico had finished their mating dance
so I've been standing in these woods for
two weeks now hunting fireflies and the
results of the film I'm taking for it
have just been amazing and it's been a
beautiful trip
you
[Music]
you